[Music]
I'm Edith Rowena I've been around MIT
for many years when my husband came in
1963 we arrived here and have gotten to
know people in the community and the MIT
community itself very well over the
years so it was a great honor for me to
be asked to interview presidents wives
for their experiences and I have talked
with three presidents wives whose
experiences covered the period from 1957
to 1990 they cover the administration's
of Jay Stratton Paul Gray and Betty
Johnson I should really mention before
Paul Gray because she came first in the
in the sequence and Priscilla and and
Paul Gray unfortunately Leia weasoner
who is also a very active wife when her
husband Jerry was president was not able
to participate Jay Stratton died this
year at the age of 93 and Jerry Wiesner
died just before our interviews at the
age of 79 so and Leia is an ill health
and not really able to participate in
this series the Women's League was eager
to capture something of the experiences
of these women in connection with the
80th anniversary of the Women's League
the Women's League itself has gone
through many transitions over this
period of time and the wife of the
president is always an honorary
chairperson of the league so they have
particularly interesting things to
I personally was particularly interested
because I think the role of women in the
period that these women were occupying
the the wife role is exceedingly
interesting as well as the whole history
of the period which included so many
major pieces of American history that
MIT became related to whether it was the
McCarthy era the Vietnam War all kinds
of issues of the military role in
science and each of the wives has had
experience in dealing in one way or
another with some of these issues that
their husbands were concerned about I
found the talks with the wives
exceedingly interesting and each one
does a I think a marvelous job of
conveying how they handled the
responsibilities all in admirable ways
the league it was happy to do this as
part of its own historical exploration
of the league and the Institute and
wants us to become part of the MIT
archives and its historical record
because we believe that the wives of the
presidents can enhance the perspective
of the whole history of the MIT
community so it's with great pleasure
that I hope you will listen to these
remarks by case Stratton Betty Johnson
and Priscilla gray it was certainly
wonderful for me to talk with them and
get to know them even better anything as
much as I can remember I'm a little
nervous too you don't have a monopoly
[Laughter]
yeah okay okay okay first of all I want
to say how happy I am to see you and
have the chance to talk with you and as
you know this part of the Women's League
program to record some of the history of
MIT through the eyes of presidents wives
and one of the things I did and I expect
you did too was review your written
remarks to the annual meeting and I
noticed that you started out talking
about entering the the new house and
your new life as the in in the role of
president's wife with a little
trepidation and you described it as
redefining your life could you tell us a
little about that well I had a tiny bit
of practice in redefining my life
because when Jay was made acting
president we were asked to come in from
Belmont with our three daughters two of
whom were teenagers and and we had two
years in the in the penthouse at a
hundred memorial and that was kind of it
was a good time to try to understand
what the presidency was all about and
what expectations they had of me and so
it was very happy and then at in 1959 we
moved down to the President's House and
that was really scary
it was as you know a huge house and
nothing had been done to it in heaven
knows how many years and the corporation
in their most enormous generosity
let us redo the whole house and I had
the joy of working with Betsey Beckwith
who
is an architect and designer and we had
that was really a learning situation so
that was my beginning in the presence
house now now you you said that you got
some idea what was expected of you what
was expected of you well as I look at
the role I had been very active in what
was then known as the matrons and is now
the women's league and there was a great
deal of reorganization of that that
organization and so I was deeply
involved in that but I felt that the
role that I had to play was as a learner
and as an advocate and I worked with the
women students and I did a tremendous
amount of hostessing because it seemed
to me that if you wanted to learn about
the faculty and you wanted the faculty
to to know each other then entertaining
was one way that it would work and we
did a great deal of entertaining in the
president's house and we organized a
number of interest groups which went out
into the far reaches of the Boston
community and integrated the newcomers
into the faculty who lived in those in
those locations and that was that was
lots of fun no are you talking about the
matrons Kay or about you about the the
president's wife organizing these or was
this a matrons activity aunt wife was
then the chairman of the matrons as
opposed to the president and
I had done a lot of work and so I simply
carried that out with with the president
and the president of the matrons and the
reorganization turned out to be a very
positive thing and we had lots of good
results from it what were the sorts of
things you did well beside this this
introduction of the of the newcomers we
started the classes in English for the
foreign speakers wives we started a
program in which the faculty kind of
adopted foreign students that was a
program that went on and instead of
being a kind of tea party organization
the women's group then became became
active in performing service a service
organization so that was to me a very
exciting part of it mm-hmm
were there a lot of women at that time
who were who were involved was it easy
to get people to participate because now
so frequently one of the complaints is
that it's so hard I know you want to
talk a little yes of course in that in
that era there were not many women or
wives of faculty and staff who had jobs
and so it was a perfectly easy thing to
call a meeting at 10 o'clock and expect
you know a quorum whereas you have now
got to roll with the times and evenings
are the ones times that are scheduled
that people can come so volunteerism
really flourished in those days do you
think it's a loss that you know what if
you compared the those days to to these
days and the lives of your own daughters
for example do you think there are some
losses or have
have been gains or I think that there
are a lot of losses I think that and I'm
thinking of the daughter who lives in
Newberry she works all day very hard
professionally and when she's got gets
home and does dinner for her family
there's not a great deal of time or
energy to give to volunteer work
there's Friday and there's Saturdays and
Sundays but that's family time too so I
don't know how how Cleo and the present
chairman of the league really get they
have a harder time finding volunteer
workers that I'm sure do you do you
think there were ways in which the MIT
community was enriched by having women
who who weren't so dedicated to their
own careers in those years I think that
it made for much more integrated faculty
that knew each other and appreciated
each other's talents and I was smaller
but more enthusiastic group mm-hmm
I mean as I look back over the personal
relationships and more informal exact
opportunities for people to get together
and and when Jay was president did you
feel that you were very involved in his
career and the issues that were of great
concern to him were there particular
ways that you got involved in those I
think that a great deal of Jay's work
went on in Washington and in the
academies and in in in Affairs that I
really had no no part in he would come
home and we would discuss what was going
on and
excitement of of his work in the
academies and in the science and in the
engineering academies and in his work in
establishing notion and that kind of
thing and then I would bring him up to
date on what was going on not it from
his office point of view but what was
going on I was his Tech Talk you told
him what was going well do you want to
talk a little bit about MIT was so
involved so central just so many of the
issues that were going on at a national
level do you want it I think many people
wouldn't know what no sure was do you
want to talk a little bit about what
some of those issues were that no
sherwoodk developed was the the law of
the sea and he was appointed by Johnson
to pull together a committee that would
eventually write the law of the sea and
it became notion and is one of the one
of his accomplishments that has been
spoken of a number of times that period
at MIT was a was a very well it was
quiet but it was it was also very
productive I mean there were the
tensions were at the minimum and
everything was going forward and as I
recall the only incident that I can
recall was a rather funny one when when
we were in the president's house and the
the tuition was raised from 800 to 1700
and there were a large group of students
who marched up in front and down of the
president's house saying
1700 is too damn much and we all stood
at the window
and looked at each other and wondered if
this was the beginning of a trend which
unfortunately but you what about the
whole issue of moving you know three
teenagers into that house what kind of
impact did it have well their lives and
yours it it had a great deal more impact
on their life I think then than mine we
lived in Belmont which was a marvelous
neighborhood that the kids could run up
and down on their bicycles and and skate
and all of their friends were within a
few blocks and there was absolutely no
fear of anything and we didn't have a TV
so fortunately the people across the
street whose children the same age did
have TV but when we came into the
President's House we did have a TV and
but the children missed very much their
friends and they stayed at Buckingham
which was where they all graduated from
but and we had a student who drove them
up and picked them up every day but they
miss their friends and and later on and
they they weren't ashamed of the
elegance of the President's House they
would bring in droves and and of course
all of their rooms were on the back of
the president's house which is looks
into senior house so that turned out to
be a source of great interest in excited
that's time they get binoculars I don't
know about the binoculars but they
certainly use their bicycles until there
was certain amount of tut-tutting
so they were it was suggested that they
used the sidewalks and not not the ones
and not the lanes in the campus you
mentioned the the elegance was that a
and they're having to eject feel
comfortable enough to have their friends
come into this elegant house was the
house elegant and where your family
quarters was that it it was elegant and
we used the entire house as a home when
Jay came home we had we had drinks in
the living room and the living room
served as a beautiful library I found a
whole lot of pictures of our first
Christmas there and it's really quite
fun to to see what we had all the
decorations and so forth but it was very
it was family too I mean there were
books around and it wasn't used always
ceremonially we lived in that house
because when I think of my teenagers it
would have been a problem having a a
formal house with a bunch of teenagers
well I must say they didn't throw things
around but they felt perfectly at home
and Laurie had adopted pet raccoon which
she brought down to all of the cocktail
parties we tried to get them to serve
hors d'oeuvre but they were little they
weren't terribly good at that but they
were but Laurie was very good with her
raccoon and that the conversation and
the conversation so that that worked
uh-huh and what were you you mentioned
in the course of your talk I know that
you had so many very famous people who
came into the house and who were who
were some of those well there were the
early astronauts and that was that was a
really a sensational afternoon they came
and
the faculty a lot of the faculty were
invited and of course the girls went
around collecting all of the signatures
and so forth and that was lots of fun
and then we had oh we had
Morris graves and we had Fiedler and we
had CBS top reporters and it was really
a marvelously kind of international
place that everyone felt rather
comfortable in and and we shared it with
them with the faculty and with students
whenever we could and it was it was
really it turned out to be a lovely full
life well you you've described yourself
prior to this is a rather shy person
wasn't easy for you to be in the role of
the hostess at those events well I tell
you I had done quite a lot of theater so
when I knew that there was a party I
said to myself now you know what your
role is and go down and do it
and so finally after after playing a
role it became it became me uh-huh
what what had you done in the theater oh
when I did a lot of I'm trying to think
what the group was but there were
several groups and I started out when
when the theatre part was over on
Boylston Street and I I worked with the
as a total non-professional simply
because I adored theater and then we did
theater in the round in and walker and
was this an MIT act audience among all
MIT I send bill green was always the
director and that was
mm-hmm and what did you do what was your
oh I just played whatever role they also
you actually acted I mean you weren't
just yes right right what did you have a
favorite part no I did two or three
Shakespeare things which was fun I did
them with K bold who was a very close
friend and very active in in the matrons
and and that was fun and a number of the
MIT professors now did did the theater
group have anything to do with the
matrons was that a matron so the matrons
were took the female roles and the
faculty men took the others and during
the radiation lab we always put on a
marvelous musical written by cabled and
Arthur Roberts did the music mm-hmm so
it was a very lively place uh-huh so
there was so that was really it sounds
like a great deal more social
interaction than one would oh yes
imagine these days and the never a dull
moment just like there isn't no uh-huh
but for other in other s about the
Centennial right okay okay that you tell
us the Centennial was perhaps the most
exciting point in our life and it came
in 1961 and it was a three-day maybe
three and a half day symposium and it
started with the uses of atomic energy
and then then we had representatives
from all of the disciplines arts and and
medicine and philosophy and of course
science and technology and it all it
culminated in
marvelous dinner at the the at the
Statler Hilton and it was the first
banquet I'd ever had to design and this
was a real challenge and fortunately
John Burchard was always looking over my
shoulder and but we designed a wonderful
dinner which started out with Locke with
a lobster and then spring lamb and and
wonderful little are they called the the
little things that are made of ferns and
it was the first time I'd ever used
those and so we were flown in from
Canada and then we had a lovely Lunt
lovely salad and then dessert and then
we went up into another section for
coffee and they involved steps going up
and we led on and I had gotten a lovely
Brown taffeta dress was bright rather
quite along not a train but it would
hung down and back and as I was going up
the stairs and this was my first
breathless gown so I was I thought this
was really something and someone stepped
on my the back of my dress and so how
the train was derailed I recovered in
time both the dressing myself and we
went on to coffee but that was that was
what I remember most about that dinner
part uh-huh the trauma of your strap a
strapless gown uh-huh but it all turned
out very well and that was really the
beginning of
the 20th century fund and that ought to
be mentioned because we were aiming for
66 66 million and in the end in two and
a half years we made 88 and from that
rose many many of the new buildings
around the campus it was a very exciting
time of building and McCormick Hall went
up then and the Center for Strategic not
strategic but for well for engineering
and life sciences and it was a and the
boathouse
it was just a time of real excitement
from an architectural point of view and
of course with McCormick Hall the number
of women which had been a very serious
advocate for women and their place at
MIT as Leia Wiesner had carried forward
and we and we only had 268 women when
McCormick Hall was started and now we
have 40% of our students as as women
which is a real triumph for MIT I think
okay you you are very oriented to women
both I think for ideological reasons and
maybe for personal reasons from having
grown up with a lot of women how many
how many were there in York well I had
three sisters all of whom were supposed
to be boys and three daughters
[Laughter]
whether you wanted to or neither who had
to preserve women's issues now did your
children ever think about participating
in schooling at MIT your daughters no
alas they inherited my genes and our
eldest went to Stanford and took
political science and our middle child
went to Vassar I went to went to
Radcliffe and our youngest went to
Vassar and they are all professional
women but none of them none of them took
science and engineering or technology
mm-hmm now no kids as you look at your
daughters do you do you think you might
have enjoyed and having their
experiences rather than yours if you had
your life to live over no I think that I
think I have just as interesting life
and possibly more so than they have
there I think that if you are a
professional our eldest is a is a
professional planner for for youths
employment in London and our youngest is
a works for the brother-in-law of the
king of Saudi Arabia and she's a kind of
controller of finances which wouldn't
interest me at all and Kerry is is very
involved in technical and computer work
with her husband and I'm I've just
gotten my first word processor and and I
look at the book and it frightens the
Wits out of me to get an MIT freshman I
know or even my grandchild to me and I
think
uh-huh do you think that that J regarded
you as participating in his career or so
much of it was in Washington that that
wasn't I think it was really a
partnership in which I was doing my
thing here and he was doing his thing
here and there and that our
communication put together a total kind
of scene and we did have done a great
deal of traveling together and even then
he had his he had the things that he was
to do which were usually I had to do
with government and education and I
would do I would do the arts and and the
the health situation and and that is how
roughly we divided could you tell me
about one or two of your trips and
specific trips and what the well what
they know about the the trips here
involved going out and with and meeting
all the alumni and and and that was very
exciting because I saw a lot of that and
we also went to South America and and
Mexico and so forth and in Europe we saw
alumni also and that was the the I
always got involved in an alumni Wives
so that was exciting and I saw a great
deal more of the country than he did but
then when we left MIT we went to the
Ford Foundation and in that in those
five years we did we traveled all over
the world because the foundation at that
time had projects all over the world
and that was terribly exciting
what was your was your role in relation
to Jay at the Ford Foundation similar to
what it had been when he was president
of MIT very much so it was the first
time that in a way I'd been off duty
and had a chance to really develop what
I was interested in and at that time I
joined the Bank Street College Board and
did their art and education program and
then I joined the National Board of the
YWCA and I headed an art project for
Mayor Lindsay and it was all very
exciting very new and and again a a an
exciting learning situation was that
connected you mentioned that at MIT this
major architectural program had
developed well Jay was still in the
president's office was that what really
started you on getting involved with the
Arts and actually what started me in
getting involved in the arts was when I
got down when we moved into the
president's house and those vast walls I
said looking around salutely nothing on
them and I thought well the thing to do
is to get art in here and the best way
of doing it was to borrow it and I had
the help of a marvelous Committee on the
arts and MIT people MIT people MIT
alumni some from New York a lot of
gallery connections and so we filled up
the walls quite quickly all on long
except a few things
and from that we branched out and
started a an art project for students in
which every Christmas we filled the
gallery which was then next door here
with all kinds of prints usually 14 I
didn't building 14 yeah usually under
$100 but very good prints and posters
and small sculptures and they would come
in and robes and buy them and we did
that for two or three years and then
when we left the art committee went on
in a very quiet way though there nothing
much happened but when Jerry became
president he saw the possibility and
pulled together the Council for the Arts
of which which is now going for 23 years
and and that has really changed the
whole atmosphere I think of MIT did you
remain involved in that when you were at
the 14 so I still chair the annual
meeting committee and and I I have the
fun of sitting on the executive
committee and and working very closely
with the council do you want to talk
about some of the art I mean count there
saying well I thought that if that
councils been enough I think the I think
Jerry and and Jerry Wiesner Jerry
Wiesner and also too I can't think what
his first name is Johnson Howard Howard
Johnson had gotten the the
feeling that this was a great
improvement the campus and because we
had so many buildings howard went to
work and really developed the whole that
the whole plan of architecture which
which decorated these rather stark
buildings and if you look around there's
hardly a view that doesn't have
beautiful trees and flowers and bushes
and howard was the one who really went
ahead on that under under jerry we
started the whole sculpture and MIT has
the second largest sculpture collection
on the west coast
not really caused it's a very very
distinguished one and then of course the
gallery is our gallery which is now in
the weasoner building is world-renowned
i i think it is almost a secret
MIT but in the Boston community and in
the national community and international
we are extremely well now how do you how
do you explain its lack of popularity
within the MIT environment I think
there's a slight weakness in
communication and I think that a lot
more has to be done to develop more
communication and more interest in in
the students and in the faculty Ellen
Harris has done an absolutely superb job
in her five years as associate provost
for the Arts
and she has turned turned the Institut
around but we still have a long way to
go uh-huh
well well to what extent is the MIT art
gallery related to the educational
activities at MIT
it isn't very much that's what we need
to work on one of the one of the
committees of the council is the grants
committee and that has been the most
successful I think of all the committees
which we give away $75,000 in seed money
to students and staff and faculty for
projects and the seed money is given so
that with instruction on how to raise
more money from by themselves they have
produced a tremendous ten years and what
sorts of things have come out of that
well one of the projects last year was
the young painter and I'm Chinese
painter and I can't think what his name
is
who came to the council and asked for
$300 to to do some paintings of the of
around MIT and we looked at the sample
of his work and we said $300 isn't going
to get you anywhere here's five go out
and do another and he came packed with
another and and they were so superb that
we said we are now as a student this is
he's a graduate student on architecture
a young Chinese doctor who escaped and
came over and is a painter
and we said go back and do 12 more and
we'll buy the whole thing and we did and
they have now appeared on postcards
they're absolutely gorgeous paintings
watercolors and so that's one one
example of being a little proactive and
in doing grants I think what you're
saying there isn't an intimate
relationship between the the gallery and
any educational part of the Institute
that right will that come about do you
think or is there something very hard on
it uh-huh
or is there something in the in the to
culture problem that everyone I don't
think so because Ellen who is head of
the office for the Arts has in her in
her council heads from all of the
departments so that she's working from
the top down and we're trying to work
from the bottom up and surely we'll meet
now know in the course of all of this
have you met some of the artists who
have made some of the sculptures and the
major pieces Rytas campus yes there of
course every time they change it show
there's an opening I tried to avoid
openings because you have to bounce up
and down and not really see what's going
on and there are talks by the by the
gallery director Katy Klein who's
absolutely first-rate and so that's that
so she recently did a wonderful tour for
the matrons I know for things for the
she's an extraordinary women's league I
should yes yes right and and what about
some of the sculptors who have done some
of the large pieces on the campus like
the big sale well the big sale I know
pretty well because Margaret
Jeanne McDermott who wanted to give a
great gift to Cecil green a Cecil green
and Eugene McDermott were partners in
Texas Instruments and when Cecil gave
the earth science building the
McDermott's wanted to do something very
special and they gave the court and the
weekend that Margaret and Eugene and Ida
Rubin and Jerry Rubin all came up to our
farm in Vermont it was a lovely fall
weekend and they were discussing with
with Jay and with the rest of us sitting
out on the terrace with drinks what we
might what what would be exciting and we
came up with the idea of a sculpture and
then the question was who to do it and
what scale and so forth and so we went
through a couple of sculpture sculptors
who did their their my cats and then we
you actually commissioned met cats well
we went to their galleries and we looked
at the maquettes and we brought the mac
hats up and have various people look at
them and then we decided that Calder
would really be marvelous and so we were
Ida and I were asked to go down to
Roxbury Connecticut where colder had his
house and a huge barn he spent half of
his time in Paris and half of his time
in Roxbury Connecticut and so he came in
and this huge barn was covered with all
of the working models of his sculptures
and we went up and down the aisles and
up and down the aisle
and then Ida and I looked around and and
thought about this space and said
wouldn't that be marvelous and Sandy
King said you liked it
you know sandy always presented search
sandy Calder uh-huh
always wore his red shirt and he had
bush of white hair was he I don't know
who Santa Calder is the oak alder I'm
sorry I'm sorry
yes and so I didn't know the sandy right
and so we said how do you think it would
look and he said I think it's got great
possibilities and so we went home and
bought the news back and he said and and
Margaret is a Margaret McDermott is a
great art collector and has a gorgeous
collection in her house in Texas in
Texas and she liked the idea so sandy
sent up a maquette and the maquette was
different from this one and we said it
looks a little skinny it ought to be
have a little bit more width and so he
went back and did another magnet and it
was just what we wanted and so then he
went back to France and he worked with a
steel manufacturer who also worked in
the shipyards and so he drew the the
model for it and then and that was
approved and then he went to work on the
on the big piece how long did this take
what was the gestation year took a year
and but it was very exciting when he
brought it over and put it all together
there on the on the campus and then it
was dedicated in 66 by the McDermott's
and that was a very exciting moment did
you were you involved at all with the
Louise Nevelson sculpture no I wasn't I
i I've been very fond of her work but I
would never have chosen that I thought
it was very spiky and not not typical of
her work and I I didn't like it I don't
like it that's an affirmative and and
and could you talk a little bit about
some of the other things that you have
that you like particularly on the campus
in the way of art well on aesthetics
that I think that most of the most of
the pieces after we left and were chosen
by by by the Johnsons
he became the chairman of the board of
the MFA the Museum of Fine Arts and has
a marvelous taste for sculpture and so
he went to work and and did and it was
through him that the sculpture really
developed Jerry a weasoner was
influential in in getting a number of
sculptures in the weasoner plot they're
out in front the plaza the first
sculpture that the Arts Committee
commissioned was that little one outside
the the library
and the hodza and and we were terribly
pleased with ourselves and John Burchard
was was very was very supportive in in
this early art committee and he said you
know we have a little money that has
been put aside and I think we could
afford something that wouldn't say we is
this MIT MIT art committee and I think
that we could afford something and he
said you look around and see what you
like and well for twenty thousand there
wasn't a great deal that you saw and
could light but hots he was doing a
whole series and he came to MIT and he
liked what he saw and he said he would
do that for us and if you look at it now
if the scale is much too small and so
we've been agitating to have it move
someplace in something a little bit more
exciting put it higher so that in its
place could you talk a little bit about
the greens and they you know some of the
people who have been such great MIT
benefactors in the time you have been
here well Cecil and Jay were both the
class of 23 and have been very close
friends and Cecil comes back once or
twice a year and he and his wife were
marvelous partners in in philanthropy
and she was very much interested in
education and in in women and did a
great deal for setting up scholarships
and fellowships and and he has been just
enormous ly interested and
generous and everything he's given
they've given millions and millions and
so have the McDermott's and all of their
scholars from the southwest and Margaret
came East this year to meet with her
scholars now could you talk about that
the the McDermott scholars whatever well
the McDermott scholars were set up for
people who had not the advantages they
are very often mexican-americans and and
very often Indians this is exclusively
an MIT program yes yeah well the release
the one I'm talking about ISM and they
now have well over a hundred and they're
very very bright people and very often
they're brought here at the beginning of
the summer so that they have an intense
kind of orientation of planning and
these are undergraduates undergraduates
yes all of them are undergraduates and
they they have done very well and I was
sitting next to one this fall when
Margaret came up and gave a luncheon for
all of them and this girl is a senior
and is going into medicine and was so
excited about it and she said they've
done such marvelous work here I'm I'm in
I'm in biology and in that field but I'm
going back to medical school and I'm
going back to that region because I feel
that's where the need is but if you
could see the stars in their eyes that's
that's what is so exciting - Margaret
okay this brings me to your own interest
in activities related to to serving
people and the development of richer
lives
and I know you've been very involved in
issues of the Aged and maybe some things
that you have done since in subsequent
years after long after your president's
wife role well when when I got to be
about seventy four three or four there
were so many decisions to be made should
wear should we should we go into a life
care community said we stay at MIT
should we should we move into a house
should we stay across the street from
the from the infirmary which was always
a great a great advantage and so I
thought well if if I'm having these
problems maybe the rest of my age group
is having the same and so we started out
with doing two seminars a year on the
problems of aging and aging successfully
so that you we started out with housing
because that way that was selfish me my
interest and then we started out on all
of the all the medical problems that one
faces and how how what the proportion is
in our aging group who has these
problems so that they are a universal
enough so that they would attract enough
attention and then what are the problems
and what what are the solutions and what
is the cutting age at edge that's going
on in solving these medical problems and
we do two a year and they've been very
successful so far we've handled things
like the brain
we've handled a nutrition we've handled
the breaking of limbs and home care and
artificial limbs and we've always drawn
on top people in both MIT and in the
whole medical community Harvard and and
the U and these have been under the
sponsorship of the league of the league
and the medical department that's is it
so they've been a boon to the entire yes
MIT entity have you had good
participation at the I think so it has
built built up every year and I'm about
to Cleo and I are about to meet with
Cleo Simo who symbols the Past Present
surprised President Lee and who has been
so enormous ly supportive in all of the
programs to decide what we should offer
for this spring do you want to talk
about the celebration of your 80th
birthday I was thinking about that I'm
thinking that there I have the feeling
that there are two times in life when
women are candid about their birthdays
when they're 20 and when they're 80 well
I was lucky enough to have my 80th
birthday coincide with the 80th birthday
of the Women's League and Cleo Chimel
who is the most creative character I
know thought it would be fun to have a
birthday party and it was indeed the
most elegant birthday party and the most
fun that I've ever had my kids flew in
and did a real roasting can you can you
share some of it can't door they were so
naughty that they told all of my
weaknesses now yeah well I to wit to wit
that I taught them mathematics by
playing blackjack
but I I we had always a contest in the
summer when the watermelons were right
as to who could win the spitting contest
they brought up the fact that I love to
hunt and skin and eat animals and they
dwelt on that too long well they just
they I don't know how I'm ever gonna
live it down and and didn't you want to
talk a little bit about your birthday
present my birthday present was the most
exciting thing it was the fact that we
could now in my name do put together two
seminars in the fall on critical issues
and envelop in that the aging
successfully so for we will have four
seminars and or lectures a year and it
was most it was I had no idea of this
and it was it absolutely took my breath
away it has been a very exciting time
and I also got a briefcase carry all of
my bits and pieces around and a gorgeous
gorgeous bag to take me traveling